so first is this your first horror movie
since devil and if so what was it about
the boogeyman script that made you think
now it's time to jump into the genre
again yeah I mean as she dies tomorrow
did you see that oh yeah I mean it's
genre genre not as hard into horror as
this and devil may yeah I think what
this was I mean first and foremost
Stephen King and and joining his kind of
his Pantheon in in some sort of way was
a real honor and then um
reading this script and talking to the
director Rob Savage he you know he knows
this genre so well I felt like I was in
great hands and the first conversation
we had he said
have you seen Ordinary People which is
one of my favorite movies of all time
and so we talked a lot about that and a
lot about grief
and that combo made me want to do the
movie so devil was I think it was 2010
car and the technology and all that has
come a long way since then so was there
anything on the set of the boogeyman
that kind of made you stop and go like I
cannot believe that's what it takes to
make it look like that on screen now
yeah I had not done uh that much green
screen stuff so that was incredible
um the the mocap suit that the actor had
who was just fantastic chasing us around
and we were wrestling with him and
fighting with him and that was
amazing it made me uh leave uh having
even more respect for the filmmakers and
actors that do that on the regular did
it make you want to try performance
capture you know it did it did
um because it's such a physical thing
and that when I grew up I was a I wanted
to be a dancer so I I did think at times
I wonder I wonder if I could be any good
at that I mean that's a that's the thing
and you and I have talked about this is
the thing about
doing different genres you get to you
know learn from so many really talented
people okay so with that in mind then is
there anything you learned on the set of
the boogeyman whether it's from Rob one
of your co-stars you name it that you
are eager to maybe further explore in
the genre in a future film well I I mean
Rob would do these things it sounds so
little but he would you know there's a
scene at the beginning which is the
short story with with David and I and
um there's a section where I'm getting
um scared and amped up and worried and I
get up and go for the door and so every
time I would get up and go for the door
rather quickly it's it sounds so small
but Rob would say slowly get up
and slowly walk to the door and then
look back at David and
again it sounds like nothing but you do
it and it creates so much more tension
so it's little things like that along
the way that Rob kind of uh directed me
to do that I I learned a lot from him if
I do this again I hope to carry it says
little details and subtleties that make
all the difference and the attention to
detail when it comes to pacing too I
always think about that with inserts
with horror movies on set it's like I
don't want to waste my time doing that
but you absolutely need them to build
dread yeah and where you put a camera
you know whether it's up high or down
low and then you just have a whole you
know uh a different view into the scene
and then with what do you do with
Boogeyman I think the the score and the
sound that he put it is so terrifying
and wonderful
um you know it's uh it's gonna be fun to
watch him as he just keeps going in this
uh in this genre and others he's a
really talented director I got somebody
High Hopes I saved my one spoiler
question for last we will brand this a
spoiler part of the interview you could
talk about it freely but I was I was
wondering after having gone through this
experience with his family how do you
think the whole Boogeyman fight might
impact his work as a therapist and his
approach to that work that's a really
good the question I mean I would imagine
going back to work that he would be um
that he may maybe take on different
philosophies and therapy be it maybe go
uh even deeper
um and I would imagine that he would and
hopefully uh
um would grow to be an even better Dad
um so so maybe the answer to the
question is he might move more away from
helping others and more towards helping
the the people he loves most I would
believe that I didn't get the rap sign
so squeeze in one last silly question
really short I promise I promise
um let's say you as in real you you
encounter a boogeyman okay who is the
first person in your life that you would
run to and tell that would believe you
and also help you fight it I would run
to my wife and she would save the day as
she always does that's the right answer
that's the right answer thank you again
yeah congratulations thank you so much